quella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono vari j e parliamone delle p
cita di questa cazzo di maglia parliamo
perché ragazze forno tutto su instagram
che le ceche il mezzo mondo le facessi
faceva le foto tatro c'ero anch'io la
collana ma mai con chi gravi di parlarsi
e da quando ho iniziato a vedere foto in
giro l'ingente costa maglietta ho detto
che sono l'unico che non ce l'ha il tra
l'altro non so perché ragazzi a parte
gli scherzi non c'è un lato ce l'hanno
fatta senza naso st vabbè voluto andare
a cafu a prenderla potuto comprare una
maglietta che la mia faccia cioè il
cassiere mi ha guardato tipo e no io
sono un suo fan ne faccio bene cosi
prima di cominciare ragazzi come sai che
devi partire con la falda settimana che
questa settimana è stata vinta da mario
bros wii castiga mario philos che ha
fatto questo disegno bellissimo dove ci
sono io e privi pie veramente una figata
complimenti mario perilli se sarà casca
il telefono o michele secolo che non
facevo un blog come ai vecchi tempi
perché ormai i blog sono diventati tutti
tipo video speciali come avete visto
ragazzi in questi giorni da circa un
paio di mesi ormai ho iniziato a fare
video un po diverso ci ha iniziato a
fare cose nuove tipo defa vj shock che
sta andando benissimo e chi non lo
conoscesse sarebbe tipo un vero blog
dove faccio vedere che cosa mi succede
durante la settimana ovviamente le scene
più belle non è che vi faccio vedere io
che cago che però potrebbe essere una
buona idea ho già fatto due episodi che
sono piaciuti tantissimo quindi vi
ringrazio di cuore
niente ragazzi cercherò di fare del mio
meglio tra l'altro sto organizzando un
mega spoiler news della madonna raga sto
per andare in texas
dal 6 all 11 aprile sono a sarà ospite
la tappa del motomondiale che sarà in
texas e quando sarò lì ovviamente farò
una marea di video non vi preoccupate
per i video perché in questi giorni sto
sgobbando come una vacca per riuscire a
registrare più video possibili per
coprire tutti i giorni qui non ci sarò
quindi tranquilli che usciranno video lo
stesso altre wikinews ragazzi per la
quale mi state mandando un miliardo di
messaggi ma non posso ancora rivelare
niente e che ultimamente sulla mia
pagina di instagram non mi sa che si sta
quando muore domani sto pubblicando un
sacco di foto ultimamente con in colate
di youtube uberti non mi sa che si sta
con catene dire tutti insieme stiamo
facendo un progetto del quale non posso
parlarvi ma tra poco verrà
ed è una cosa epica veramente epica ho
fatto cose
vabbè non mi sa che si stagliano dimore
cavallo al 3 e pc news che vi voglio
dire che è stata e rompendo il cazzo da
un paio di settimane con le richieste di
the forest uscire la mattina e andare al
bar sotto casa prende un cornetto e c'è
il tipo del bar che mi fa cose che fai
the forest a porcia di quella [ __ ]
tranquilli che arriva armi calmate gli
orgasmi comunque sia ragazzi siccome
sabato voluto registrare questo blog
però sono sincero non sono stato a
preparare domande perché in genere vos
correre tutti i commenti per trovare le
domande serie che mi fate però ragazzi i
mezzi giorni veramente non ho avuto
tempo di farlo perché sto cercando di
coprire i giorni in cui non ci sarò e
andro in texas quindi non ho avuto tempo
di cercare le domande per il fa vi
risponde questo video lo sto registrando
all'una di notte perché sono veramente
alle strettissime quei tempi sono come
morto fatti non sto più dormendo non so
se si vede però ho deciso di fare un
mini scart aggio dei pacchi anche oggi
ho trovato qualcosa da fare lo stesso
quindi ragazzi ho preparato questi due
partite sono gli ultimi prima capra il
prossimo punto posta lo devo aprire
quindi tranquilli che tra polo apro così
potete inviarmi idilbi st contenti a uno
spacchettamento sano dopo una vita e
mezza allora quando riapro punto posta
una cosa vi chiedo non mettete scatole
dentro altre scatole è inutile non serve
a un cazzo c'è una fan art della madonna
sempre comunque meglio delle espressioni
che ciò sola maglietta ragazze a
giudicare dai colori del parco credo che
sia una ragazza da per me l'ho mandato
non ne sono sicuro dopodiché c'è un
cuore c'è scritto schiaccia e
inquietante oddio ma un antistress di
anti stress così io li adoro ragazzi
sono un orgasmo per me ha un bel ragno
grazie tesoro concilio li adoro questi
cosi sono veramente figli quello che
avete sentito non era al cestino ve lo
posso giurare posteri selena gomez con
dei ladroni sexy così io posso limon
armeno nel tempo libero penserete mica
che io possa fare robe del genere sul
serio prove vi ringrazio per il pensiero
e il marshmallow per fare il samba amica
ed ha portato perché non faccio la
ciardi bagno che non so se riesco a
battere il mio record dell'altra volta
però ci provo cambi bunny ravvivanti
cabib anni aviv chabib anni
[Applauso]
giovanni
[Musica]
legami fanno cagare i marshmallow mi
fanno veramente cagare a quanto ho fatto
secondo amico non solo fatto l'altra
volta non lo farò mai più
come ultimo ragazzi ho trovato un cd con
su scritto guardalo in diretta
considerando che è scritto su un cd
chiamato banana digital ho paura di
infilare che mi escono le banane dal
computer lo guarderò alla fine ragazzino
peso giusto per curiosità e per carità
se con dell'ultimo pacco ragazzi
possiamo a questo che sono curioso ormai
sono curiosissimo l'altro ci sono
attaccate le mie figurine su questo
pacco questa è la prima che ho visto
appena l'ho aperto ed è sempre comunque
una faccia migliore di questa qui
ragazzi ormai o la va o la spacca
vogliamo che c'è dentro un mouse a forma
di macchina che costa ben 5 euro 5 euro
di mouse
perché mi serve perché comunque sia io i
miei di spacconi votai gioca gli horror
che il lancio via quindi grazie mille
ragazzi questa qua mela dovete spiegare
ma proprio spiegare ma chi è che cazzo è
un incubo una bottiglia con delle ha
scritto leggi che cazzo ne quella
bottiglia ci sono delle penne dentro che
hanno di messaggi o ragazzi proviamo n'è
uno a caso giusto per questo qua nasce
mi sembra mi sembra promettente ragazzi
siete allora gli angeli esistono ma a
volte non hanno le ali e prendono il
nome di idoli c'è tipo questi di prima
va dai ragazzi e questo era l'ultimo
pacco in assoluto non ne ho più
incredibile quindi vi ringrazio per
avermi mandato tutti questi fatti in
questo periodo appena freeroll secondo
un nuovo punto posta potrete inviarmi
tutti gli altri pacchi così che io possa
fare altri mega scartati vi chiedo scusa
ragazze non ho fatto il fa vi risponde
però veramente se non mi metto a montare
adesso che sono quasi le 2 questo video
finisco alle 6 del mattino ragazzi spero
che vi sia piaciuto un mi piace a vita
per lui perché dio mio supera veramente
la masturbazione il godimento di
schiacciare sto tizio spero che siamo
100 ragazzi cose subito piaciuto affatto
un momento è un mi piace anche a
presenti facebook è coniugato tale
iscrizione sensi di skater e ci vediamo
al prossimo video ragazzi
[Musica]